what is your favorite curse word okay
you say yours and we'll say it together
on one two three one two three Taylor
Swift is answering all of our burning
questions
the singer appeared on Wednesdays
episode of The Ellen DeGeneres Show and
Ellen tossed a series of questions at
her including this one what is the most
rebellious thing she ever did as a team
check it out probably when I like put
Joe Jonas on blast on your show that was
too much wasn't yeah that was too much
okay I was 18 yeah
we laugh about it now that's good that
was healthy yeah yeah just all right
teenage stuff there Wow that's held on
to you because I don't remember that at
all okay so the incident that Taylor is
referring to is from a 2008 episode of
Ellen when Taylor was promoting her
album fearless and explained to that the
songs were about boys and love naturally
when Ellen asked if any of those songs
were about Joe Jonas who was her
boyfriend at the time
Taylor revealed that they had actually
broken up there's one that's about that
guy uh-huh that that guy's not in my
life anymore unfortunately
I know buckle up guys because it was
awkward we haven't talked since actually
so it's like yeah but you know what
someday I'm gonna find somebody really
really great who's right for me when I
look at that person I'm not even gonna
be able to remember the boy who broke up
with me over the phone in 25 seconds
[Applause]
okay so the song that she wrote about
Joe Jonas is actually called forever and
always
this is sarcasm at its finest and I'm
here for it
[Music]
also you know that you're famous when
the most rebellious thing you did as a
teenager was going to daytime talk show
and throw shade at your teen heartthrob
ex anyhoo during the segment Ellen also
tried to get Taylor to reveal the name
of her next single I can't tell you that
that's crazy I was gonna try
can you sing some of it okay for effort
Ellen at least you tried
but in true Taylor fashion she did admit
that she dropped some Easter eggs during
her appearance on the show
really yes it's on I'm not supposed to
do it every word no okay she also shot
down the rumor that she was somehow
involved in Avengers endgame which was
released the same day as her song me
there were some fans that thought I had
something to do with Avengers endgame oh
really
which I would which I would have loved
to have been asked but I wasn't no she
wants to be in it at all yeah because we
had the single coming out the same day
and I have a song that was called
endgame and so they were like oh my god
she's gonna defeat Thanos and I let
everyone down yeah yeah again so this
appearance actually marks her first talk
show interview in two years and it's her
first time back on Ellen in four years
she intentionally did no press to
promote her last album reputation at
that time I point this phrase there will
be no explanation there will just be
reputation cuz I am dramatic yeah that's
a very dramatic thing but it rhymed it
was kind of catchy and I yeah and so I
stuck with it and this is exactly why I
love you Taylor of course there will be
lots of Taylor news to break down as she
releases new music so be sure to keep it
locked on et until next time I'm Holly
Stephens bye for now
[Music]